et on accueille François Patriat en
direct bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
notre invité politique ce matin François
Patriat sénateur de la Côte-d'Or
président du groupe RDPI Rennes les
sénateurs de la majorité présidentielle
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes en
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale bonjour Julien l'Écuyer de la
Voix du Nord
bonjour monsieur patria bonjour
évidemment parler de la réforme des
retraites le texte qui sortira ne sera
pas celui du gouvernement mais celui du
Sénat c'est ce que dit ce matin Gérard
Larcher dans les colonnes du Figaro
c'est un avertissement gouvernement et à
la majorité présidentielle non c'est une
volonté que je peux comprendre le Senna
depuis plusieurs années dépose sur le
Cannet un amendement dans le prochain
boite finance de la sécurité dans lequel
il propose d'ailleurs
65 ans sec
sans mesure annexes 65 ans sexe
on peut quand même penser que
aujourd'hui
il y a un peu de changement par rapport
à ces demandes quand on voit les
demandes réitérer des républicains à
l'Assemblée et on demande républicains
ici au Sénat donc normal il est normal
aujourd'hui que le Sénat veuille
s'approprier cette loi en disant nous
l'avons porté c'est notre loi c'est la
raison pour laquelle je pense que infini
la République seront amenés à l'avenir
un peu de satisfaction ça fait comme
vous le dites il s'agit quand même
quelques années qui le propose ça fait
quelques années que le gouvernement le
refuse et là ils ont la main vous pensez
qu'ils vont en profiter le gouvernement
le refusé jusqu'à présent parce qu'il
est proposé une autre une autre retraite
une autre réforme des retraites qui moi
qui avait mon accord à l'époque donc on
accepte pas cette réforme paramétrique
puisqu'on était sur des formes
systémique bien donc maintenant le
gouvernement considéré que compte tenu
de l'urgence qu'il y avait un maître de
l'équilibre dans les comptes la caisse
des reliques caisse de retraite il
fallait une réforme paramétrique bien
elle rejoint effectivement le chef de
l'État l'a dit Madame brandadi la
proposition qu'on fait la républicain
ici donc allez qu'il veuille se
l'approprier moi ce que je souhaite au
bout du compte pour la majorité pour le
pays c'est qu'elle soit votée
je pense que la réécriture non ce sera
quand même malgré tout difficile on voit
bien d'ailleurs que c'est sur un ou deux
points il y a pas beaucoup de points
sur lesquels qui voudraient troquer
contre des mesures acquises à
l'Assemblée je prends par exemple les
mesures des 43 ans pour les 14 16 18 etc
on voudrait sur lesquels il voudrait
peut-être revenir alors que l'engagement
de dernière minute avait été pris en
accord avec l'Assemblée nationale pour
mettre à la place une mesure pour les
femmes pour une surcote pour les femmes
aujourd'hui celle-là elle coûte 300
millions il y en a une autre alors il y
a d'autres mesures qui vont dans le
mensonge sur cette surcotte pour les
femmes après 63 ans est-ce que vous
allez la voter vous êtes favoris je
pense que si elle est proposé par par
les républicains je pense que le
gouvernement donnera la vie je pense je
sais pas un avis favorable je pense que
nous la votons
de 5% des des pensions pour une femme
qui a donné
on explique une dame qui a 60 qui a tous
ces trimestres qui a 63 ans pourrait
prendre la retraite éventuellement mais
si elle va 64 ans elle aura
moi je souhaite que là il y a 74 comme
tout le monde et qu'elle a une sur code
bien entendu mais il était prévu à
l'origine je verrai la nature je n'ai
pas vu l'amendement tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui c'est un amendement que nous
pourrons voter oui effectivement qui va
dans le bon sens du départ dans le bon
sens un sur le CDI senior parce que ça
aussi c'est un autre rapport de la
majorité sénatoriale votez en commission
est-ce que là vous c'est quelque chose
que vous pourriez voter aussi c'est
quelque chose sur lequel nous pouvons
avancer de même que
de même que la
retraite progressives la retraite
progressive me paraît aussi et pour cela
il faut que nous discutions largement
au-delà de l'article 7 je viens
d'entendre madame Lubin à l'instant
c'est compris que la volonté de
l'opposition c'était que le texte ne
soit pas voté donc qu'on le veuille ou
non ça veut dire qu'ils ont mis en place
une stratégie d'obstructions
est-ce qu'on a une idée de combien ça
pourrait coûter parce que c'est un
allégement de cotisation encore une fois
j'allais dire mais c'est des pertes
fiscales pour l'État effectivement alors
là il faut déjà il faut retrouver
l'équilibre les 300 millions pour les
femmes aujourd'hui si on laisse que ce
qui est à l'Assemblée nationale parce
qu'aujourd'hui bien entendu il y a les
républicains ils sont ici et qui veulent
voter leurs amendements et leur texte
mais il faut pas dans le même temps mais
contenter les républicains à l'Assemblée
nationale qui seraient tentés de voter
contre le texte parce que on aurait des
faits parce qu'ils ont obtenu donc de
l'équilibre il y a l'équipe il y a un
risque que le vote des républicains du
Sénat empêche les républicains de
l'Assemblée de voter le texte bien
entendu mais je dis que ça pourrait
crisper une partie du groupe les
républicains là-bas donc il faut garder
cet équilibre aujourd'hui une autre
question qui se pose monsieur Patriat
c'est que à force d'accorder des mesures
qui vont résoudre les injustices
finalement le bénéfice de la de la
réforme ce se pose il a déjà été réduit
de 17 milliards a dit à 10 milliards
alors il ne va pas falloir trouver des
recettes complémentaires je vais vous
donner les chiffres exacts parce que je
les ai repris hier soir j'ai rencontré
hier les deux ministres
l'accélération Touraine aujourd'hui
apporte 17 milliards 7
en plus il y a sur la caisse accident du
travail et maladie professionnelle
donc on est près de 20 millions
20 milliards
donc si vous si vous retranchez de cela
les milliards que nous accordons dans
les mesures compatiatoires et qui sont
nombreux dans toute personne ne parle en
tout cas pas l'opposition aujourd'hui
pas les syndicats pas les syndicats on
arrive à environ 7 6 et demi 7 milliards
donc ce qui fait que on arrive presque à
300 millions près au 13 milliards et
demi qui permettent d'équilibrer le
système donc il faudra trouver dans ce
débat 300 millions pour que le système
soit équilibre
complémentaires de que proposent les
républicains c'est par exemple une
convergence plus rapide sur les régimes
des régimes spéciaux avec le régime
général une façon de gagner de l'argent
assez rapidement j'entends bien mais
pour ce qui me concerne je n'y souscris
pas et je pense pas que nous le
souverain je suis pas sûr parce que on
l'a bien vu qu'il y a un moment où il
faut que la parole que tu as soit
respectée je pense que là reprenez on a
pour la SNCF on l'a fait la SNCF on a
changé le système on l'a fait pour le
nouveau entrant tous ceux qui ont signé
par que quelqu'un qui rentre dans un
métier c'est un métier de transport de
l'énergie ou autre qui a signé un bail
qui dit je manque dans cette carrière je
gagnerai peut-être moins qu'ailleurs je
serais peut-être moins salarié j'aurais
peut-être moins de bonnes conditions
mais je sais que je partirai plutôt à
l'époque etc ils ont signé revenir sur
la parole me paraîtrait alors là mettre
beaucoup d'huile sur le feu dans le
débat aujourd'hui les républicains qui
disent c'est injuste c'est-à-dire ces
régimes spéciaux on va mettre 70 80 ans
les supprimer entre la clause du
grand-père et la durée de la retraite
des gens qui sont dans les régimes
spéciaux il y a une injustice vous
entendez ça j'entends surtout le fait
que
républicains ont été longtemps au
pouvoir ils n'ont jamais touché au
régime spécial alors je veux bien
aujourd'hui être plus blanc que blanc
mais malgré tout ce gouvernement et le
premier gouvernement qui va mettre fin
au régime spécial et ceux qui n'ont pas
su le faire à l'époque Audrey qu'on
aille plus loin aujourd'hui moi je pense
que sur ce sujet là j'entends bien qu'il
va y avoir une colère populaire
importante qui aura des manifestations
le 7 que le pays peut être bloqué une
journée dans tout cela
gardons gardons l'esprit de
responsabilité d'équilibre et de justice
qu'il y a dans cette loi n'y touchez pas
parce que vous avez peur des blocages
vous avez peur
pour moi c'est une question de principe
de les engagements de prix quelqu'un qui
rentre dans des conditions changer la
donne en cours de route c'est pas
possible mais cela dit comme on le
disait il reste la question de recettes
supplémentaires où va-t-on trouver les
moyens de rétablir cet équilibre jusqu'à
13 milliards
ordinateur Olivier Hainaut parlait d'une
signée un amendement pour augmenter d'un
point la CSG sur le capital pour ce qui
pourrait rapporter un milliard 5 c'est
une mesure j'ai vu aussi des mesures
comme ça qui ont été proposées par le
groupe modèle à l'assemblée qui
reviennent ici non le principe est clair
pas de taxe pas de cotisation
supplémentaire on fera sur des économies
sur d'autres secteurs à côté on peut le
faire on le fait déjà avec la caisse
aujourd'hui
excusez-moi monsieur Patriot je vous
interrompre mais cette cette question du
pas d'impôt sur supplémentaire c'est
c'est un axiome en effet de la pensée
gouvernementale je sais pas si vous avez
entendu les propos du gouverneur de la
Banque de France qui qui quand même qui
remettait en cause ce dogme et disait un
bon impôt c'est pas un impôt supprimé et
on a l'impression que vous baissez
beaucoup de
d'impôts vous n'en met au final on n'a
plus les moyens de financer cette aussi
cette ce régime des retraites ce qui a
pas
d'abord les retraites doivent pas se
financer par l'impôt c'est clair
en fait elle se finance par le système
cotisant un actif qui paye pour les
retraités c'est ça le principe bien il
vous a pas échappé que la France est le
pays on paye le plus d'impôts il vous a
pas échappé que la part des prélèvements
obligatoires dans le PIB la plus élevée
en France dans tous les autres pays
aujourd'hui et il me semble que la
politique menée par le gouvernement et
par le chef de l'État Emmanuel Macron
particulier a donné des résultats nous
étions tombés en dessous du seuil des 3%
souvenez-vous nous avons aujourd'hui le
chômage des jeunes le plus élevéoles
bleus le chômage veut dire je
l'employabilité des jeunes la plus
élevée que nous ayons jamais eu nous
arrivons à 7,2 % la croissance et
aujourd'hui quand même une économie qui
fonctionne parce qu'il y a eu un signal
de données de la politique de l'offre
qui a été menée et des baisses dépôts
qui ont profité à tout le monde la taxe
d'habitation ça profitait à tous les
Français tout le monde mais je pense
aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs on l'a bien vu
tous ceux qui créent pour leur
établissement l'ISF que que la
suppression de l'ISF a ramené beaucoup
plus d'argent dans les caisses de l'État
qu'il y a ça fait même ne rapportait
donc vous allez trouver du coup l'argent
qui manque mais on peut faire des
économies sur notre secteur on va
regarder moi j'ai pas je n'ai pas j'ai
pas encore vu j'ai regardé les tous les
amendements nous allons étudier pendant
10 jours mais vous avez bien compris 20
milliards de trouver pour le financement
13 milliards et demi pour le pour le
déficit truc que nous devons contenir et
le reste pour financer des mesures
nouvelles qui sont des avancées mais oui
personne ne parle beaucoup des avancées
qui a eu quand même quand on prend
est-ce qu'avant dans l'amendement des
républicains il y avait les carrières
longues les carrières hachées la
pénibilité l'employabilité seniors non
non aujourd'hui c'est quand même Grand
Prix peut-être pas suffisamment hier
j'avais un débat sur ce plateau demain
bien entendu si on pourrait le ratio
l'améliorer si le salaire des femmes
rejoint le salaire des hommes
aujourd'hui la différence entre les deux
comblerait demain je crois que
il faut travailler sur ces secteur là
aujourd'hui et c'est peut-être l'effort
qu'on peut demander aujourd'hui aux
entreprises aujourd'hui qui sont un peu
quand même un peu mieux pendant ce débat
c'est pas beau quoi
d'intervenir plus de pouvoir augmenter
les salaires et que le salaire des
femmes rejoigne celui des hommes ça
c'est des engagements qui en effet
pourraient avoir lieu il y a quand même
eu déjà un index qui a été créé et ce
qu'on va pas suffisamment loin
d'ailleurs
je pense qu'il faudra aller plus loin
oui c'est vrai sans doute sans doute
avoir des mesures que contraignantes en
tout cas plus incitatives c'est pas pour
la contrainte moi je suis pour la
citation mais en l'occurrence ça m'a ça
prend du temps
l'équilibre est contenu à 300 millions
près aujourd'hui il va falloir les
trouveras sur mesure à côté
excuse-moi vous vous parliez du fait
qu'il y avait certaines
injustices que vous combliez que que qui
ne sont pas forcément mises en avant
mais est-ce que une ancienne avancée
certains justices
des injustices qui ont été résolus le
fait était que on a l'impression quand
même que le gouvernement a fait preuve
parfois de de soucis de communication
autour de ça j'en veux pour preuve là le
ministre du Travail Olivier du soft qui
a longtemps venté comme d'autres à les
1200 euros brutes de minimum
contributifs sauf que visiblement cette
mesure elle va atteindre que 10 à 20 000
personnes ce sont les chiffres du
ministère du ministre du Travail
lui-même qui a longtemps dit 40000
personnes voire même plus auparavant
est-ce que est-ce que concrètement vous
ne regrettez pas quand même qu'il y ait
eu des des baies au niveau de la
communication du gouvernement alors je
vous rappelle mais je crois que là en
fait un peu de petites assis hein le
répétition que l'engagement du chef de
l'État c'était de dire 1200 euros pour
une carrière complète au SMIC
pour une carrière complète au SMIC et
les gens qui auront une carrière
complète au SMIC lancée en 1200 euros
pour les autres encore vous dites pour
les autres ça va quand même concernera
que pour les autres personnes pour les
autres pour les autres ça va quand même
une avancée sans précédent il y a un
million 800 000 personnes parmi
lesquelles 60% de femmes qui ont une
hausse de leur retraite mensuelle qui
rentre 35 ans 70 et 100 euros par mois
si vous avez 70 euros par mois de
retraite supplémentaire utilisant pour
moi ça vous faites 900 euros par an
compte tenu je sais que les retraites
sont petites faibles mais quand même
c'est pas mal au de 1200 euros il y aura
les avancées pour 1800 1800 000
personnes
que c'est encore une fois dans la
communication gouvernementale il y a
quand même eu des ratés j'allais dire
même presque depuis le début puisqu'on
nous a parlé du fait que ça allait
combler une partie de la dette française
puis après que ça allait peut-être
servir à financer la politique de santé
et la politique d'éducation puis en fait
c'est simplement pour rétablir
l'équilibre des retraites enfin
concrètement est-ce que vous avez réussi
vraiment à faire de la pédagogie sur
cette question je pense que vouloir
faire de la pédagogie sur sur en mettant
comme action le fait qu'on rejette total
totalement le fait de passer de 62 à 64
la pédagogie est difficile parce que
tout ce que vous pouvez faire comme
pédagogie sur le reste n'est pas audible
pour ceux qui sont résolument obstinés à
ce qu'on travaille dans le plus mais je
voudrais répondre à ce que vous venez
d'évoquer à l'instant vous dites les
multiples facettes qu'on a voulu donner
à cette classe de loi mais je l'ai dit
hier aussi ici sur plateau si on
travaille plus
on produira plus longtemps ici on
produit plus on prendra plus de
richesses et ces richesses elles
permettront effectivement demain d'avoir
des recettes supplémentaires pour
d'autres services peut-être pour la
santé peut-être pour l'assurance sociale
cependant aujourd'hui je crois que ça
aussi moi je ne l'oublie pas aujourd'hui
c'est pas l'équilibre des retraites qui
va le financer c'est pas les moyens
qu'on va gagner mais c'est le fait que
la France travaille plus parce que nous
avons besoin de travailler plus nous
avons pu vivre moi j'ai recruté la
retraite à 60 ans en 80 pendant parce
que écoutez bien parce que la
démographie était pour nous et tous les
responsables politiques et syndicaux que
je vois le reconnaissent nous avions une
démographie à 4 pourra aujourd'hui la
démographie nous rejoignons les pays
comme l'Italie comme l'Allemagne
aujourd'hui et le fait d'avoir demain
1,5 actif ou 1,7 actif pour pour traiter
le permettra plus d'ailleurs on le voit
bien dans la fonction publique écoutez
dans la fonction publique ou il y a
maintenant moins d'actifs que de
retraités 0,8 points ça coûte 30
milliards elle est top 1 François le
chef de l'État à appeler le Sénat
enrichir le texte sur quel point votre
groupe le groupe Renaissance va enrichir
ce texte ou l'améliorer
peut-être je crois qu'on va déposer des
amendements plutôt en commun avec ceux
qui veulent voter le texte de loi
aujourd'hui je vous rappelle que sur ce
texte de loi il y aura des républicains
qui seront similaires puisqu'on porte
sur les mêmes c'est-à-dire par exemple
sur les parents d'enfants handicapés
pour les gens qui vont s'occuper de qui
vont s'occuper des aidants à côté on va
le faire sur ce sujet
vous allez durcir les conditions d'accès
par exemple c'est un des amendements
déposé par les républicains les
conditions d'accès à la SPA c'est
pas en fait qui est une bien sûr une une
aide pour les personnes âgées mais pour
les pour les personnes les personnes
étrangères ils veulent allonger le délai
pour y accéder non touchera pas ça non
je pense que le votera pas non le vote
pas
sur la pollution de réversion moi je
pense qu'on pourrait avancer
d'aujourd'hui encore sur l'emploi des
seniors on peut encore avancer sur la
pénibilité on a toutes les amendements
sur ces sujets on a quelques temps
aujourd'hui d'abord vous savez dans le
site toujours en exemple
des gens de cas concrets individuels qui
sont en fin de compte pris dans le texte
de loi dans les 40% de gens qui
partiront 2 ans avant les autres ils
sont déjà traités ces cas-là donc
aujourd'hui je pense qu'en matière de
pénibilité je pense que l'emploi des
seniors on peut encore il y a quelques
amendements de dépôt d'ailleurs le
groupe déposera à nous 30 amendements
des prêts de 2000 où je trouve
il y a une volonté d'obstruction de
l'Opéra justement j'allais vous dire
est-ce que vous avez un espoir que ce
texte il soit voté à l'issue des 10
jours d'examens ou c'est quasiment
infaisable avec les 4000 amandes alors
j'ai compris parce que si on prend
aujourd'hui même si on fait aller si
t'ouvre quand tout va bien on fait entre
12 et 15 amendements à l'heure
vous avez compris quand même qu'on va
débattre pendant 106 heures l'assemblée
a eu 66 heures est-ce que sur un texte
dont on parle depuis des mois dans tous
les éléments pardon sont connus
aujourd'hui on n'est pas capable en 106
heures en réduisant le nombre d'orateurs
de prise de parole d'explication de vote
d'avancer sur ce texte je vois bien donc
il faut il faut réduire parce que ce
matin dans Le Figaro j'ai relâché dit
qu'il utilisera tous les moyens
constitutionnels et du Règlement pour
arriver au bout des débats vous le
soutenez je salue je l'ai vu en matinée
avec les présidents de groupe je salue
sa volonté de dire qu'il y a des
éléments très importants qui après
l'article 7 il y a des éléments de la
loi très important auquel il tient
auquel nous tenons aussi auquel le
gouvernement tient qui doivent être
discutés et votés et que moi vous savez
le Parlement
il est pas fait seulement pour débattre
il est là pour concrétiser j'ai eu des
débats
et qui vote pas pour moi
en commission mixte paritaire à l'issue
de de
cette période je pense que c'est parce
que nous souhaitons aujourd'hui
effectivement mais moi je souhaite moi
je souhaite comme le Gérard lacher alors
je sais pas quels sont les mesures on
peut prendre pour qu'on y arrive mais je
souhaite que il y a beaucoup de mesures
y compris le vote bloqué au beau hein
je souhaite
ce choix de vouloir accélérer les ébats
vous vous êtes derrière
la gauche a-t-elle donné sur les débats
sur les retraites François Hollande
Touraine a-t-elle donné 106 heures non
pas la moitié du temps du temps de
Fillon même chose donc on a donné plus
de temps que jamais il y a eu un débat
avec les partenaires sociaux qui a duré
trois mois tout est sur la table
aujourd'hui
ce que vous pensez qu'on 106 heures on
n'est pas capable si on veut si on met
4000 sans amendements redondant à la
virgule reprenant j'y cru comprendre
d'après ce qu'on m'a dit hier qu'il y
avait la moitié des amendements qui les
amendements similaires donc est-ce que
vous savez l'image qui a donné
l'assemblée l'Assemblée nationale aux
français
bien sûr non mais elle veut un
débattement en disant changeons de
société aujourd'hui ça on peut on peut
faire on peut faire ce débattement
est-ce que ce texte de loi nous fait
changer de société on peut le faire
pendant une journée on n'est pas obligé
de faire pendant 4 jours juste question
parce que la gauche hier c'est prononcé
pour le dépôt d'une résolution qui
permettrait d'avancer sur le sujet de la
réforme du régime autonome des des
sénateurs est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
réfléchir à une réforme à l'heure où on
demande un effort tous les Français bien
entendu bien entendu mais il faut pas
essayer de montrer la vanille que tel ou
telle d'abord nous séparer spécial dans
une caisse autonome si tu vois
différents je vous rappelle je vous
rappelle en plus dans les mots ça on a
des gens si vous décrivez le régime
autonome c'est un régime spécial c'est
pas pareil du tout mais en plus en plus
vous avez pas échappé que parlementaire
c'est pas un métier
pareil pour le députés aujourd'hui alors
est-ce que vous seriez prêt à une
réforme du même type que les défis
exorablement inexorablement le Sénat le
Parlement reste aligné sur le reste bien
entendu une dernière question Julien
mais mais je ne voterai pas je ne
voterai pas je ne voterai pas là la
résolution présentée par Guillaume
Gothard et parler vers demain
non non bien entendu le faire comme ça
aujourd'hui on va discuter le bureau
discuter on va on va je crois que il y a
une instance dans le Sénat capable de le
faire d'être responsable là le système
de la caisse de retraite devra devra
évoluer mais dans le même temps se
posera tout le statut des parlementaires
à côté parce qu'on peut pas retirer de
cela
une question qui vous fera certainement
sourire on va terminer sur notre
positive c'est qu'on assiste en ce
moment à une vague de de Castex Mania
Jean Castex qui est cité par par des
ministres notamment Gabriel Attal comme
un formidable comme candidat pour pour
2027 ou il est cité par d'autres membres
du gouvernement est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui vous fait sourire vous dites
que finalement si réussie à rétablir les
RATP qui réussit les JO il sera sur les
bons rails pour 2027 moi je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui ouvrir le débat sur 2027
aujourd'hui c'est criminel un criminels
que je veux dire parce que si on veut
effectivement rendre plus difficile le
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron qui doit
être qui doit être quelqu'un de réforme
de réussite auquel je crois auquel je
participe et que je soutiens faut déjà
sauter l'étape et aller à l'échéance
suivante alors que les Français sont
habitués toujours à voir l'élection
suivante surtout les hommes politiques
qui vont protéger leur avenir moi je me
concentre aujourd'hui sur les quatre
années qui restent avec Emmanuel Macron
je suis encore parlementaire pour trois
ans pour faire en sorte que ce parle de
soirée après pour les candidats j'adore
Jean casting c'est un ami c'est
quelqu'un de respectable est-ce qu'il
est-ce qu'il souhaite même être candidat
je n'en sais rien est-ce qu'il sera le
meilleur candidat je ne le sais pas il
va de soi que on verra ça en temps voulu
aujourd'hui ça fait partie des petites
musiques ça du tissu autour de la
politique quotidienne pour aller penser
à peu près autre chose mais là moi
j'aime beaucoup de gens un ami
j'apprécie beaucoup d'hommes politiques
autour pour l'instant on aura l'occasion
d'en parler
du Nord oui sur la sécurité routière on
a eu un grand échange et on répond aux
questions de des lecteurs et puis je
voudrais simplement avoir un petit mot
j'ai appris donc le départ de Clément
qui nous accompagne tous les matins nous
à la matinale les invités extérieures et
donc je voulais le saluer lui souhaiter
un bon voyage c'est adorable merci
beaucoup
notre émission spéciale réforme des
retraites on passe au débat dans le club